hello to Australia commentaries Aladdin
2019 the film about a boy and his lamp
this is a show where you'll get our
thought process behind the honest
trailer stick around for some deleted
scenes responses to your dumb comments
and a tease for next week's honest
trailer but I couldn't do it without
friends like these Joestar hey Daniel
revered know what's going on
none I'm just excited that we have to
identify movies now like the first few
bars of 90s hip-hop song colleagues on
the on the outro for this song right
mm-hmm yeah another one this was if we
seem like we're scrambling for things to
talk about it's cuz this is Aladdin
you've probably seen this film in 1992
and enjoyed the comedic stylings of
Robin Williams and this is that movie
without that but otherwise quite similar
yeah Dan you liked it I did I thought
that it was a fairly perfunctory remake
yeah the original movie until Will
Smith's Joseph Smith showed up as the
genie he puts his own spin on it
I love the how they used to visually
they I thought it was a good translation
from animation to live-action he wasn't
just a personating Robin Williams I
think he made the role his own and then
from there I think they they folded in
some new stuff to the story enough that
I was not just sitting there going over
the same beats like I was with another
remake that came out I loved it but I I
there was enough there for me to go like
alright this is a nice little companion
piece you know with the cart with the
animator the genie gets Harvey this time
what's not to like heck yeah and now the
negative side of the table I didn't hate
it there was things I liked but there
was too much that made me puzzled and
frustrated I is kind of where I think I
fell cuz I remember the first time I
watched I was like what was that yeah it
was like the whole show is just like the
first 30 minister just like
to see Disney's manager for like the
first 30 minutes I was definitely my mom
and an Applebees she was starting to get
the highlights coming I watched it a
second time and there's there are
elements of it I really like but none of
them are really able to to be their own
thing or get explored you have Guy
Ritchie not making like a Guy Ritchie
movie but also not like shooting a
musical super well and you were mad that
this was not a heist with like for
company gentleman talking about like
rhythm and Bonnie was like I'm upset
yeah like if you're going if you're
going to hire like why would you hire
like Wes Anderson to do - not Wes
Anderson a movie like if you're gonna
hire Guy Ritchie there are certain
things you expect from a guy ritchie
movie which i think so why haven't you
catch him at a certain point in his
career when he will do what you ask
yeah yeah when he knows how - what great
art look these things are you're not
making a Ladin but then but then why pay
someone a Guy Ritchie rate where you
could have you could have paid anyone to
make this movie I don't know it's pretty
like CG heavy like this is a big thing
to juggle like oh well even though the
plot is all laid out so yeah I just I
don't know it just you get someone who's
made this something the size of King
Arthur without getting the quality and
then you know on the parts that they
don't really change your update it just
feels like they're it's a summary piece
like you know these beats and then this
stuff that they do update doesn't fit
the stuff that they don't update and
like some of the songs they don't change
at all and then other songs they update
for Will Smith and they work and they're
good and that's that's how you update a
musical but then other songs they don't
so you have weird karaoke whole new
world that that doesn't fit into
Jasmine's new song that doesn't fit into
the newer version a friend like me and
just doesn't fit together as frustrating
for me a lot of things I liked that did
not work as flavors yeah talked over
your whole time Daniella the genie is
warned up like to reiterate this genie
F's making it a completely different
movie yeah I don't think you can I can't
have too strong of reaction because I
think we say in the trailer is like I'm
I'm sufficiently cowed by my Disney
overlords at this point it's like I
can't get mad about the same thing over
and over again when they've done this
with Cinderella they've been feeding the
beast they did it with Lion King like
well I've seen The Lion King
right and so I'm told that I've seen the
Lion King yes this is what surprised me
was the Lion King I did not like because
I felt like it was a fairly inert
complete remake lesser in every way and
that's what surprised me about this
movie is like this 100% what I expected
from this movie and this movie actually
surprised me by mixing in some different
flavors that I thought worked and made
it distinct where the Lion King to me
was just like a lesser recreation beat
for beat word-for-word of a different
yeah so Beyonce doing Nala with her
Houston accent and when you want know
well let's watch this movie
unfortunately land 2019 here we go boy
we make the best wishes from Guy Ritchie
the director of Lock Stock and Two
Smoking Barrels snatch and you just well
you have a debate out to the writers
room and said yeah it was one of those
great moments where Spencers like solve
the puzzle I'm not telling you what the
puzzle is and lon said Mitch got whipped
in the Bitsy's no I distinctly remember
not that it matters but I added the
Mitch
I think the original was like Bev - in
the Bitsy's or something yeah coming up
with like fake basically cockney slang
because we love Guy Ritchie and yeah I
think that RocknRolla
was one that got cut from this list but
yeah I was like Bob's your on - in the
Bitsy's then Robin took gold in the
mid-season then because I remember I
have a buddy of mine with a English
girlfriend whose name I can never
remember and dismissively refer to her
as midge the first British thing that
comes to my mind I'm sorry I don't know
why like you know midge I'm sure it's
something like marigold or something
like that I added the midge and I think
it all came together quite well hope he
doesn't watch the video with the other
pictures where I think mine is like cool
in it yeah the magical child you have to
channel all right keep conscious okay I
made that one up comes another magical
Disney Fantasy that dares to ask what if
poor people had upward mobility
oh but with people this time you've
heard all the complaints about
live-action Disney remakes or - soulless
creations bland corporate storytelling
and cynical risk-averse cash grabs well
yeah we should all know the deal by now
but as far as soulless cash scraps go
this one is clumsily entertaining enough
to reverse Allen it is it's clumsy
Platina charming sort of she's making it
like you're watching Disneyland's
Agrabah sing-along stunt show
[Applause]
we go to the galaxy's edge next I want
to assemble my own jizz flute
we didn't we didn't pull it but it's
sometimes uh uh you know we moderate
what some comments you know we tried to
weed out the worst of the worst there
was one that I actually put through
because it just made I just thought it
was hilarious it said so typical of this
channel the shill for galaxy's edge
definitely took a look at us who's every
other video is you're destroying the
world by owning everything with a Disney
is a monopoly joke yeah yes weird take
we took their money to shill for the
customizable gym it's so good that
social media gave everyone sjw's their
kids flutes yeah anyways it is a great
value those three dollars made of
parkour courses this is done without now
it's parkour and really came to life
[Music]
famous story like a handmade the Cheney
would like to friend Jasmine's new
psychic time-freezing powers and typical
Disney force diversity they says that
ins continent yeah right but don't worry
grown-up fans there aren't too many
changes to your precious cartoon in fact
all the characters are still
two-dimensional with the cast upon knows
who aside from jasmine will definitely
stay that way each Rick I liked a lot I
mean we except when Will Smith and Will
Smith carries him but he wakes up a
little bit for will I think when you're
casting unknowns
Danielle you said this yeah
because my thing with Aladdin and the
thing that bugged me the most about the
actor playing Aladdin is that he doesn't
have a strong singing voice and so for
me I do think that the benefit of
casting and unknown is that you can get
someone who you're not limited in the
way that you would were if it's like
well you know they did have to do some
motto tuning on Will Smith but it's Will
Smith you know that's fine yeah
where is it and they arranged most of
his songs to Rhett right because it's
Will Smith and you will do that but with
this kid
you know he's newer so maybe it would
have been a benefit if they had in
Aladdin that had a stronger singing
voice further musical
yes and you could really in whole new
world especially jasmine just laughs him
she's singing so yeah she's and she is a
star by the way yeah she is she she's
pink Ranger that's true so good in that
yeah yeah yeah you're right like just
pull someone off Broadway or something
like grab the Broadway Aladdin grab
Broadway Aladdin he couldn't movie act
that is true maybe he was making
everything super huge like acting is
just like have you seen the producers
movie the one that they made of with
Nathan Lane and Matthew Broderick yeah
of the stage show it is it is what
happens when you bring Broadway to film
but don't tell them to modulate
[Applause]
performance either it's Matthew
Broderick like with the camera like what
meth when you're sitting at night and
that's where he's like well mr. bloom I
don't know what's going on here and
you're like I didn't think this was 3d
on the stage that works great but when
there's a camera two feet from his face
and Nathan lines like what am I tell me
you'll be out like stuck we go it's just
like I love that show but you can't you
got it you got it you got to adapt it
you got to adapt it you can't spare that
is for Daniel's point stands find an
Aladdin who can sing karaoke get you
when they can do both
and his nipples are at your bar who went
from over the top snake wizard to CBD a
few snake oil salesman and a jasmine it
doesn't he's young man to do everything
for because she already had a perfectly
good woman for that I'll draw the bath
huh maybe she should be sewn instead at
least she probably knows that bread cost
money yeah pause I'm surprised that they
didn't bother to adjust the I guess it's
Disney but like the avowedly
unquestioning of the monarchy aspect
it's like it's not I think the people
should have a say it's like know me from
the top of my magic carpet right
remember Lance that they really love the
Queen so they'll probably really love
the princess too right there's some BS
liner they throw out of like the people
aren't happy because they can't see the
princess that's what she wants to rule
over and I guess continue yeah what they
chose to adapt don't like the the kind
of my first geopolitics scene where it's
like Jafar's like these people are gonna
invade us but she's like no war and he's
like but they will and then it's just
never addressed or we never see we we
never know who's telling the truth in
that moment right yeah I don't think
either of them would make particularly
good Sultan's well you know something
controversial should there be a sultan
well the other one that gets me is Jafar
like that's such a big fun role yeah
that you're you're a you're a snake
wizard yeah we walk around with the
Cobra staff you are not a chill dude if
you walk around the Cobra staff yeah it
would have Garth Algar Treasury
good job here he's like thanks like you
play enjoy it they kind of set him up as
the you know if Aladdin went wrong like
cuz he's like I'm just like you you like
we aren't so different you and I but
then I don't know give them a share to
history or like they could have they
could have rolled in the same crew I
hate that trend has always been
connected for their entire awareness but
just the choice to make him so grounded
when like he really doesn't get
Maleficent Maleficent whatever the word
I'm thinking of is until he actually
what malevolent yes until he grows into
a CGI demon and even then it's like a
late act three and it's too late like
you've been so chill like he's like a
little finger not like Ramsay Bolton you
know yeah I was also upset they didn't
have a prince of boo-boo-boo-boo this is
such a funny line from the cartoon
pretty cousin Prince Abboud oh yeah
you're right yeah yeah I don't know it's
a different take on Jafar I'm not quite
sure how it worked I agree I did I did
think that it was an interesting
direction mm-hmm to make him a little
more grounded and more like a guy who
built himself from the ground up but I
liked that aspect yeah like 50% more
arch yeah particularly when a lot of the
other characters were going for yeah a
broader yeah I think we got earlier go T
once yeah practice and evil laugh in the
mirror yes yeah thank and yeah and I get
why you know I think they pulled back on
a lot of the like all Disney bad guys
are effeminate and stuff like that but
there's still like places like there's
there's somewhere on the Bond villain
like level list that you can take them
without being like okay I got it
yeah he's just like chill guy with a
parent uh-huh talking about the parent
why why yeah why cast alan tudyk to just
squawk cuz they have to get payout on
two together six months
bird you play a bird yeah chicken and
Malana
yes yeah is a luck luck or whatever and
then yeah then he was k2s oh he's been
pigeon holed I don't have until Will
Smith Jeannie does his best to move it
up a notch
oh and don't let that teaser fool you
he's slightly less horrifying in the
finished product watch Disney trying to
recapture that Robin Williams magic by
casting another fast-talking 90 super
star as Big Willie throws jokes dancing
and auto-tune at you to another Arabian
night tentative stuff until you use your
final wish to this make him go buy
everything on a boat already I think
it's time that I told you the story does
that mean this whole movie is just some
BS we'll made up to get discount Jaden
and Willow to stop complaining respect
buzz we had a legitimate debate I think
we might be split on this yeah I think
that this is just supposed to be a fairy
tale that he's telling to his children
we're choice to cast himself in like
them as though all knowing was the
all-knowing wizard and his mom's their
mom is a maid
Oh daddy can't do magic anymore remember
I gave up my powers to save the world oh
yeah well it works no but see the story
doesn't work if he's like I was Aladdin
and your mom was Jasmine because then
the kids are gonna be like well then why
aren't you still the king and queen and
then he has to be like Oh cuz mom
doesn't understand that things cost
money okay yeah yeah no I think it's I
think this whole movie is a fairy tale
it's like it's bookended by you know the
framing devices this is just a story
that will smith is telling I don't know
it's one of the thousand and one Arabian
Nights damn a tick in me says that
that's he's the genie
he's the genie and it's it's how I Met
Your Mother and also usually if will is
going to tell you the story of a movie
you're about to watch he wraps it or or
yeah Fresh Prince that's usually not in
the movie itself oh that's like
on the soundtrack I mean you know you
know is is the intro to Fresh Prince a
prologue or an intro trick yeah you
don't remember the first scene of Ollie
or he sets the whole movie others
collateral Beauty booty okay
let's keep going complaining respect so
gather the family for a time-tested tale
about lying your way into powers that
would have been more interesting if it
were about Jasmine Jafar's rise to
prominence whatever unholy union of man
and peace that gave birth to Iago I
stole the story of Aladdin it's not
gonna do his translation of a thousand
and one Arabian night pause that was an
interesting little factoid Justin and
some research is that Aladdin is it's
disputed it's either something that a
French guy completely made up and back
then I guess you know pre-internet you
could really do anything at any time to
anyone and it'd be hundreds of years
before we got a call that was no luck a
pedia yeah said he just created a fairy
tale and as he was transferring the
actual fairy tales just snuck in one of
his own to see if anyone noticing oh oh
these are great but this one's my
favorite but then there's also it got a
receptionist that puts in earlier their
own headshot yeah the original version
of that they got a little muddled
because like he there's evidence or some
type of record that he might have like
heard this actual story from a wandering
storyteller which was also a profession
that is that what we would be doing if
we were around no no we'd be following
you on the story
you wouldn't know the weird thing I was
also reading in that same article that
the storyteller according to the the guy
who wrote the book looked and sounded
like Robin Williams doing a bit of a
almost offensive middle-eastern
characteristic well just to the first
movie oh he was the original right
another framing device another musical
yes those are really dumb lyrics I don't
think I realized until I watched this
version of Aladdin or the like the
nights are hot in a lot of good way yes
this one looks sort of like oh okay okay
it's a good to get tuned but yeah
sometimes you break it down there like
that it's like Vegas if your outer
children rather than not are hotter than
hot and a lot of good okay alright keep
going but as far as a copy-pasted
version of Aladdin with no Robin
Williams goes it's about as good as that
could be and apparently that's worth
something like a billion some things
[Music]
story robbing Williams I love lamp
DJ Jazzy met my dream of Giggy and
animals playing the drums Renaissance
village true Disney Vault they're just
not sending arendelle's best all right
people we should just call them this
that would make the law disappear please
like it never existed does that apply to
laws on monopolies asking for a friend
got him chills chills we are
wait let's roll right into deleted
scenes yeah can we go to the galaxy's
edge next I would have spend real money
on the fake money from a star ward the
genie would like to friend the somewhere
Jasmine lets it go kind of let it go
starry that speed up slow down think I
Ritchie does prints blue Handmaid's Tale
nip status unknown Agra bro Oh ASM Jafar
snake and shake DJ Jazzy Jeff serpent or
how come this guy wasn't cast as Jafar
look at him sand hich man in blue gin
and juice the Blues brother which Disney
Sultan are you all that jazz
mighty ruling glow arranger trap and
three stolen wishes Wicky Wicky wild
whoa Middle East lady in the land okay I
am DB Kretz Will Smith is the genie and
the Mariner Wow water well prequel
confirm you guys we're gonna keep
talking about Waterworld bottle you
can't stop us
isn't there some dumb theory about like
Agrabah is like our future
I was able to make like a Peter Lorre
reference like just he's just ripping
like that everything has to be tied down
there yeah
or does it how did this all-powerful
genie know these references so much
later yeah time is a flat circle true
detective no because William F Buckley
had to exist at some point in the
Aladdin universe to do an impression of
them and then the apocalypse happened
and they recreated a quasi Middle
Eastern / Indian society that's way more
convenient than just believing in a
magic Genie or just knowing that Robin
has some go to voices he likes yeah and
he's gonna do the oh he'll be all right
so some comments some interesting ones
popped out Victor Lima writes was kind
of expecting it to be the same script as
the honest trailer for the original led
and with the same scenes used tempting
yeah we talked about it a lot turns out
they pay us to write things we can
probably get away with it one week but I
don't know I feel like people would be
upset if we did that yeah I mean we did
we did one a little bit of that with you
doing the B start reusing a joke and we
call it out but right now Lion King is I
think if we're gonna play with that
liking is it much more suitable cuz it
is literally the same thing yeah okay
well you might get your wish granted for
us to do the exact same thing number one
I'm down for us Keith Brown sorry to
call you out but that guy's voice was
terrible was the other guy sick it's the
same guy he can do more than one voice
it's not just you Keith we get this a
lot John is a man of many voices and
he's imitating different styles he can
do you know listen to this one listen to
Harry Potter he does have a British
trailer he does a different one for
horror he does another one for yeah
there's like from the vault like retro
yeah die hard
yeah he's yeah some are more subtle
variations than others but some are
pretty different like this one is and
yeah with it is the same guy plus it's
just the feel because we've done it
before we've actually
the wrong voice before where we think
that it should be this way and then we
look at when like we I think I think we
did Toy Story and we did it in the
regular voice and it doesn't play like
when you're doing a family movie it's
like from the creators it just doesn't
like that take and his that that little
tool in John's Arsenal works so much
better for family films because I
remember there is a there's another one
of these lost trailer scripts where I
wrote a an actual honest trailer for
boyhood and it just didn't work no
matter which way he was reading it's
just not that kind of movie and then it
works so much better when we went
wordless yeah like the trailer itself so
yeah he has a he's a talented guy with a
ton of with a big range of movie voices
and this was the Disney voice FL order
rights this is one of the better remakes
where do you guys place this in the in
the Disney remake pantheon Oh me in mind
I have not seen Cinderella the Rose
still the best one I think because a
it's different enough and B I also don't
care about Cinderella as much so I guess
it also like I don't have that one that
queued up in my head the same way that I
might have like Lion King does
Maleficent it's like so wicked version
yeah i near the top not as good as
jungle book jungle book for me as easily
of the ones I've seen the one that I
prefer mmm-hmm but I liked it more than
Dumbo this one I liked it more than
being the Beast I liked it more blanking
I liked it more than Maleficent yes to
me it's Jungle Book and everything else
because they took and I hear peach
dragon is good yeah I mean peach dragon
it's hard for me to count cuz it's like
that's not really a it's not an animated
film but yeah it was good for what it
and the first one is so bizarre it's
like yeah do something right it's almost
like Jungle Book where it's like sure
it's 20 minutes of weirdness yeah that's
where I think these movies can be not
necessary because no movies are
necessary but at least like have
something to say or something different
or something original because you can
take the Disney source material that's
not great and turn it into something
meaningful like I think they did with
jungle have you seen the Dumbo one oh
it's the new the new stuff they added on
is weird and kind of self-referential
I don't know yes yeah I would love to
hear your thoughts on that if you ever
see it cuz I will I I wanted to it just
came in when yeah it flopped super hard
Oh Dumbo's out here two weeks ago oh wow
okay I have to catch up on that one yeah
any final thoughts on Aladdin before we
teens next week I don't know just it's
such a weird like mixed bag
you got the Jasmin song and they do a
different style of movie for her song or
suddenly people are vanishing it's very
stylized the rest nowhere else in the
movie unless the genie whose magic is
doing it do they do that no it's just a
lot of things I liked and they just
didn't taste good to me together yeah
okay no no that's fine yeah yeah it's
one of those it goes through you like
like Taco Bell so they'll talk Delta
fare like all of the things they put in
taco but like there's a harmony there
that this movie was lacking like you
know if if this movie had pulled off the
right combination of slightly spicy
nacho cheese a Dorito shell ground beef
I would have liked it a lot more I'll
agree with that and we'll discuss what
fast food all the Disney movies are
later I'm sure but next week it's a
BuzzFeed quiz
yeah next week what to say this is one
that this is a dead franchise will be
next week yeah yep long dead but will it
rise again
who's to say we'll find out we will next
week right here same time same place
Australian counters thanks for watching
[Music]
you